what makes a great horror movie kind of
depends on what kind of one because I
the the hormuz I made okay kind of been
popcorn horror where it's kind of a ride
you know which is very satisfying to see
with an audience because they're sort of
you get that like cheering when the
right person dies when they get away
we're like laughing and people like
jumping and then laugh about jumping
so in those a movies like that it's it's
very much about sort of the ride the
scares and I think in general just for
for horror movies sound is super
important and timing because a lot of
people don't or some some horror
directors they don't take their time
with sort of the creepiness and the
scares because you can make anyone jump
like if you just have a loud sudden
noise but it's that that Hitchcock thing
with the bomb underneath the table like
yeah if it suddenly explodes people go
oh but if they know that it's
something that's gonna happen but they
don't know when and like that's when
you're sitting there at the edge of your
seat and I think that's one thing that
worked really well with lights out just
the short was that we start right off
with a big scare you know that the thing
just comes closer and then we've we'd
scared people now they know what to
expect that okay anything can just jump
at us at any moment and then that makes
you know just her hiding on to the bed
and hearing little things that makes
that much more effective because then
you've set the precedent but then
there's horror movies that again that
are more sort of art house like
hereditary or the witch or things like
that where it's you know less about
scares and her pride and it's more about
being unsettling and really like staying
with you and and then that's you know
other means of achieving that but I
still think again sound is super
important I think that's why I like I
mean David Lynch has made some of this
he's not a horror director but he still
made some of the scariest stuff out
there and he's someone that makes his
his own sound like he's very much into
that yeah I think the sound and timing
and things like that more important then
and what I try to do is always just make
it as bad for the characters as possible
that continued sort of escalation of
just getting worse and worse and worse
like in in Annabelle creation you know
there's that girl who she runs into a
barn and then she gets trapped in there
it's like oh and then there's a
scarecrow in there that starts to come
alive it's like oh this is even
worse like how could it get even worse
well now the lights are starting to go
out now I'm gonna be here in the dark
with the thing so it's just like that
continuous escalation of to just make it
worse and worse order for your
characters as you used to use a lot of
your own sort of DIY things or whatever
you had handy when you were making films
short films back in Sweden or were some
of those things you would use for sound
effects we're just like these
inexpensive well in our apartment we
were blessed with very creaky floors
which was great I have a whole library
just recorded me sort of creaking around
on those floors and then yeah just
trying to find good sounds and and like
recording just the air the ventilation
systems like slowing that down and you
have this sort of dark drone that you
can keep in the background of horror
things that's that's really effective
and yeah I mean for doing DIY things we
did little lights ourselves you like I
did this bucket light from an Ikea trash
can and whatever we could do I mean a
lot of it would be based on things that
I would see and bound the scenes of
proper movies like ooh how can I make it
like a low-budget version of that which
still sort of stays in Maya because I
remember on an about creation they had
these quasar lights which are basically
like like tubes or whatever that are
kind of expensive or whatever but just
watching us like oh I could have used
that like I could have used just regular
light tubes but put them in the same way
and done that in a short film you know
you